[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter Lavelle
after a rather bumpy rollout the new
Green Deal is upon is co-sponsored by
Democratic buyer Brent Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez the plan foresees a radical
restructuring of the American economy
and how people will live what the plan
does not address is how much it cost how
much will we have to go into the red
become green
[Music]
crosstalking the green New Deal I'm
joined by - Chris is for Neil I'm in
Washington he's a Republican strategist
and founder of the knee Hwan group also
in Washington we have Christopher Baron
he is president of right turn strategies
and in San Diego we cross again
silverstein he's an international energy
and environmental journalist or Forbes
in other publications all right
gentlemen crosstalk rules in effect that
means you can jump in anytime you want
and I always appreciate Chris let me go
to you first here I read the the
American conservative and came across
Pat Buchanan's reaction to the new Green
the green new deal and he said well let
me just give you the title the the green
new deal is a suicide note for Democrats
would you agree with that assessment
well I do think that it's going into
that very far hard left precinct that I
think Republicans want to paint the
Democrats in order to kind of push them
off the radar from the independent votes
they need that they were able to that
they were not able to secure last time
so pretty harsh characterization but I
would tend to agree with that and I
don't believe that another trying to
sort of distance themselves saying well
it's just an idea it's not really formal
policy yet but I would agree that it is
very far left they're gonna have a hard
time dealing with it and notice two key
Democrats that you have kind of had
their hands slapped head slap by Nancy
Pelosi in regards to miss Cortes as well
so I think there is a little bit of
distance in going on in the Democrat
caucus in Congress okay Ken in in
reading this non-binding resolution I
was just struck how it's trying to solve
all problems all at the same time I mean
over over the years even members of the
GOP do recognize the importance of
global warming and and what strategy
should be applied I mean as a
conservative I can talk very easily to
progressives we agree on the problem we
don't agree on the solution that's the
problem here but in reading this this
resolution I was just I was I almost
left speechless like I am right now I
mean this is going to change what they
want to do is change the entire fabric
of the country is this going too far
go ahead
can I think that you've misrepresented
it Peter okay to be honest with you I
just agree with your premise that it's a
radical solution to a problem
the premise is is that global warming
shutting down your travel I'm not
radical
Kapaun can and the premise is is that if
global warming is an issue to be dealt
with then here are the solutions we need
to to keep in mind and it just speeds up
what's been a green energy evolution it
doesn't it doesn't change things
radically at all just now the cost will
be an issue but the sponsors of this say
that the cost of inaction is even higher
okay I've heard that argument here let
me go to Christopher I mean let's let's
examine some of the words the phrases in
this here the green New Deal the authors
say the goal has the goal of this start
the quotes stopping current preventing
future and repairing historic oppression
of indigenous peoples communities of
color migrant communities
deindustrialization communities
depopulated rural communities the poor
the low-income workers the elderly the
unhoused people with disabilities and
youth I mean what percentage of the
population is this I mean this is 50
years after the Great Society and look
that looks like half the population is
under oppression
go ahead Christopher well this is so
insane like I actually feel bad for
people who are forced to defend this
because this is sheer lunacy look I've
worked for three former members of
Congress this is not how this is not how
the process works this is not how things
are done this isn't a serious proposal I
mean we can have a discussion about
global climate change which I believe is
real and I believe that you know we do
have man-made contributions to it but
what the hell does that have to do with
full employment for everyone with
guaranteed how
for people with guaranteed health care
we're not even talking about global
climate change we're talking about a
smorgasbord of and everybody gets a
unicorn I mean it's literally the kind
of thing you would hear in a junior high
school you know race for class president
like I Gary I promise everyone we're
getting coca-cola vending machines you
know in every corner like it's just not
a real proposal and the way that it was
roll out is so ham-fisted
and so embarrassing I can't believe
there are any Democrats out there who
want to put their name on this you know
Chris they even within the non-binding
resolution it makes reference to the New
Deal of the FDR era and I would I would
question the parallels I mean first of
all the New Deal didn't end the
depression the Second World War did I
mean technically if you look at the
indices it was 1943 okay two years into
the war also FDR didn't inherit these
monster deficits and thank goodness we
we have an the the Republican Party has
to reassess this they after two years of
having controlled the Congress they did
absolutely nothing shame on them but we
still have these deficits how can we
even think about a a plan that will
remake America in every single possible
way with these deficits go ahead Chris
that's right Peter well first of all
once I get into Congress we're gonna fix
all this don't worry about it but you
know I think in terms of the New Deal
it's in terms of in terms of scope
there's there similarities in terms of
scope in terms of doing big broad new
things there are similarities between
the green New Deal and back when
President Roosevelt the difference says
President Roosevelt knew how many
branches of Congress there were our
chambers of Congress unlike miss Cortez
who frankly I said don't call her the
village idiot don't call her the village
idiot but I'm gonna call her the village
idiot is inspiring that people can rise
to office that's a good thing but when
you get to this level
you don't understand government you
routinely misspeak you don't understand
economics and to agree with Christopher
I completely agree what the hell is
paycheck unfairness I mean this is
absolute unfettered social
it's gonna fail and the Democrats know
it's going to fail which is why now
they're trying to play a whole bunch of
different games look you know it whether
it's whether it's the sweeping
legislation here or you know border
security policy they are as far left as
they come we've seen what happens in
far-left governments it doesn't work
it's not going to work here and I hope
that miss Cortez can figure out how many
branches of government there is before
her next interview okay it can I mean
there is a consensus among us here that
we have to deal with the changing
environment okay and and what we've
already had an admission here that
global warming is real and it is a
man-made as a man as part of that
problem census here but when you have
this plan come out doesn't it just
really little the position that you
might have on the environment because we
I mean how many people have I come
across in the last 48 hours it just said
this is like a card a cartoon script I
mean doesn't it denigrate in in in
belittle people like yourselves it
support more government intervention to
deal with these problems because I think
it makes a mockery of it go ahead can i
I think you guys quite honestly are
going way overboard in terms of your
description of of the objective of this
plan so there's a lot to unpack in
what's been said for starters is you
know the Obama got it came into office
in 2008 under the under the green under
the new energy economy and this is
merely an extenuation of the new energy
economy which is helped reshape the
American economy the American economy is
is really transitioning from the
industrial age to the digital age and
this is a catalyst to help me about that
okay Matt can can can let me jump in you
over there but if you're saying this
process is going on right now why do we
need the government to do it why don't
we just let it happen okay that's a
great question you read the piece that
that I wrote in Forbes I mean in the
free market is working I mean the free
the
hills of the free market are already in
motion natural gas is replacing coal
wind and solar energy are becoming
cheaper and better and getting more and
more market share all this does is aim
to accelerate the progress a little bit
and there is one other how does how does
Garrett Harris how does guaranteed
housing for everyone have anything to do
with climate change like I know that you
you want to try to dress this up and you
want to try to make this seem like a
reasonable proposal but the fact is stop
gas lighting people the actual language
of this resolution is completely and
totally off the rails like we don't even
need to get in to the FAQ that they
released afterwards would then they
pretended like it didn't happen it was
doctored no wait it was accidental we
still don't have an FAQ up now I mean
this stuff is not mainstream if you want
to have a discussion about a green
economy that's great about new
technologies that's great about stopping
global climate change that's great if
you're then gonna have a conversation
about how are we going to afford to
guarantee housing for every man woman
and child in this country guarantee
healthcare for every man woman and child
in this country guaranteeing jopley
that's not a conversation that can all
okay let me jump I'm a jump in here
because it's three against one I want to
go back to Ken here Ken I mean and I'm I
I'm not trying to be facetious here and
and I'm I want Alexander Ocasio hotels
to succeed i I think you know that let
her put her case out there but in
reading this document isn't it just
really one one big form of virtue
signaling it would be nice but it
doesn't have any details how we'll get
there go ahead Ken before we go to the
break well I mean I'm not I don't
dispute the fact that you know this is
not the end-all be-all to the resolution
of all mankind's problems I mean I I'm
I'm not sure that that that's the
takeaway but if that's your takeaway I'm
not gonna argue with it the only other
point I want to make is that when you go
into some of these distressed
communities as I am
such as in southern West Virginia in
Appalachia where the coal industry has
been decimated and the people there live
in abject poverty all right the opioid
addiction is it's just over the top the
the notion is demonym out of work all
right gonna just make gentlemen I'm
gonna jump in here we're gonna go to a
short break and after that short break
we'll continue our discussion on the
green New Deal stay with our team
[Music]
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered on Peter Lebel to
remind you were discussing the green New
Deal
[Music]
okay let's go back to the great city of
San Diego can you want to finish your
thought before we went to that hard
break go ahead yes the the which has
tremendous bipartisan support is to have
public investment in these communities
that have been sort of left behind by
the digital revolution and that includes
you know the coal regions of Appalachia
it includes the the one that that the
congresswoman represents who helped to
offer this thing so public investment in
these areas that have been left behind
as bipartisan support and so if you
start putting a 21st century energy
investments in these regions that's a
good thing that means jobs that means
opportunities that means an advancement
okay you can I don't think anybody here
on this panel or emit most of our
viewers probably would disagree with
that I just don't understand why this
all-encompassing plan is supposed to fix
all problems let me go back to Chris and
in Washington DC I lived in Eastern
Europe in the 1980s communist Eastern
Europe and they had five-year plans and
this sounds like a ten-year plan okay
where the everything is managed by the
federal government makes all of the
decisions here I mean every single
household will have to be refitted we
airplanes essentially gonna be banned
but I'm sure the rich will still fly to
Davos I mean this is this is central
planning I'm sorry that's exactly what
it looks like to me go ahead Chris Peter
honestly I just want to turn over all my
life's decisions to representative
Alexandria Acacio Cortes I want her to
handle my finances my job I don't want
to ever make another decision again I
want the village idiot to make it for me
look I think Ken sounds much more
rational on this I think the way that
he's talking about is great makes sense
but Ken I hope would admit this isn't
the Ken plan this is the far left hard
plan of trying to use those
understandable investments in terms of
energy a modernization to push a far
left hard left agenda of diminishing our
military diminishing our greatness in
the world and trying to take over the
economy here's the
problem with socialism at the end of the
day for me and yeah people can say their
socialist tenants in the way we budget
things sure we've got entitlement
spending we've got these things here's
the difference though we still have free
markets and we still have checks on that
once you give away your power to a
central government you're not getting it
back and that's the difference that
these that these far left Democrats
don't understand when in in the bubble
in Washington now that they're part of
the swamp making it worse so that's my
big concern is that they don't they
don't have it's it's it's dressed up
like a modernization plan but really
it's a far-left plan by the village
idiot and I don't think it's gonna work
well Christopher I mean in reading it
very carefully there's a huge injection
of what we call identity politics now
are we going to legislate that into law
identity politics I mean that that seems
like it's ramming it down the throat of
people actually it kind of reminds me of
the Patriot Act nobody read it but they
voted for it Obamacare nobody read it
but they voted for it okay this sounds
like deja vu all over again
for me it's right now it's a non-binding
resolution okay and it doesn't have it's
just bones out there a virtual signaling
but when you inject you want to
legislate into law identity politics I
think we're going down a very bad path
if that's the intent and it certainly
looks like it to me
go ahead Christopher yeah absolutely and
by the way I want to give Ken credit
because he's done a great job of putting
lipstick on this pig the reality is I
happen to live in one of those depressed
areas that he's talking about I live on
a mountain on the border of Virginia in
West Virginia and the very people that
he's talking about that we need to be
helping I agree with but guess what and
my precinct 76% of those people voted
for Donald Trump and they support Donald
Trump and these Democrats who are signed
on as co-sponsors of this green New Deal
spend almost all of their time
demonizing those people the only people
they don't talk about in this document
is the people who happen to disagree
with those those rural Trump voters they
have spent the last two years demonizing
those people so you can forgive me and
my neighbors if we don't take this as a
sincere you know legislative effort to
try to help those people in those areas
it's not it is lipstick on the pig
appreciate the nice sound bite
that's not what this is about okay you
know ken now we're gonna get into how
much is it going to cost okay let me
point out something that's going on as
we speak right now we have this yellow
vest movement in France and essentially
it was the the the the spark that
started all of this is that the
government brought into force a fuel tax
that affected the rural areas working
people that use their cars and now
mcrawlins popularity in this country is
at 20 20 percent at best here it seems
to me again reading this non-binding
document you're basically going to ask
the the the interior of the country the
people rely so much on their cars and
their equipment that creates emissions
you're gonna make them pay the highest
price okay because well the rich and
unfortunate always seem to get around
all of these things and everybody else
has to pay for it people that have are
least able to pay for it go ahead can
I'm sort of dismayed that the whole
proposal has been lampooned before it's
even got out of the starting gate at
least by your side of the aisle I mean
everybody here knows the legislative
process and how it works you know the
these people they weren't very they
didn't put a lot of detail into their
into their proposal it is just an idea
to start a debate it's not here is our
idea take it or leave it
everybody knows that the President of
the United States is a Republican the US
Senate is dominated by Republicans
so the idea even in general is not going
anywhere but it is all it does is try to
advance the notion that as a country the
United States ought to invest more in
21st century technologies that can help
mitigate climate change opinion then you
would agree with me hang on can't then
you're agreeing with me that this is
just a an act that is a
virtuous signaling that's all it is okay
we it's just you know this is a proposal
it has no detail it really isn't really
logical it's a wish list it's hopeful
but that's not a very good political
tactic again I think it undermines
people the good work of people like
yourself that it tried to bring
attention to these things all show about
this topic that people are talking about
it people are debating it I mean we're
making fun of it well no I mean no if
there are two congressmen Congress
people propose and go public with it you
have five presidential candidates
instantly back it up do they even read
it to even ask any questions yeah I'm
doing a program on this I think it's
really important Christopher jump in
them it's like a political hostage
situation going on in the Democratic
Party right now the truth is is this is
nuts and this is insane and it's not us
lampooning it they lampooned themselves
I mean this proposal is not serious it's
ridiculous it's a wish list and the fact
that there are so few Democrats willing
to say yeah climate change is important
and a new economy green economy is
important agree this a great guy this
agree it realistic that no one will
speak up about it
okay Chris I mean let me go back to
Chris here I mean it seems to me when we
look at the reaction of speaker Pelosi
which I think she probably has very
strong feelings about a a OC and you
know what I mean what's happened here is
that quote attendees turned into the the
wedge for all of this because of course
if you turn on Fox News she's there
darling because it's a wedge to divide
the Democrats now the Democrats because
of the virtue signaling I'm sorry can
I'm going to stay with it they're being
pulled radically to the left it's not
really where they want to go go ahead
Chris not if they want to win you know
and in brief you know when you mentioned
the Patriot Act the Patriot Act the
acronym stood for providing adequate
tools required to intercept and obstruct
Terrorism the reason I mentioned that is
most people in Congress didn't know what
the acronym meant much less read the
bill
it had sweeping effects same thing here
with the with the green new deal I don't
think they're gonna win you know it's
there's a lot of hypocrisy that
President Trump has been able to hit
them so hard on they're having a hard
time Nancy Pelosi has walls and armed
guards around her house but she doesn't
want it for the country they you know
they don't want to have that they don't
want to lose their own political capital
but they want to be able to have these
other ideas out there so they're in this
position of empowering the energy as
Nancy Pelosi says of new ideas but when
they hear how stupid the ideas are
that's when they start to backtrack so
yes it's an idea yes they're just
expressing themselves but they're in a
position where when it comes down to
policy they're gonna have to kind of
work through those things I don't think
they're prepared to do it and I also
think that some of these messages that
they're using are not working when you
look at the crowds Donald Trump has then
you have demagogue bet it will work who
should have had as rally in Mexico if
you want to represent foreign interests
so I think that there's a lot of they're
really struggling lately and frankly you
know like the president said you know I
would love for some of these folks to
run it's gonna get a lot more exciting
you know Kenny on top of the fact that
we if we're gonna make it partisan here
I am NOT a Republican I'm a conservative
okay you know considering how the left
champions open borders and then you have
a layover of this Green Revolution as it
were so you're gonna have everything is
free for everybody and you have open
borders I mean how in the world is it
sustainable when everyone will be able
to come to enjoy the fruits of this of
this amazing green revolution that the
left seems or members of the left seem
to support I mean it's ludicrous isn't
it go ahead Ken no you guys again you
guys I think we just combine it from two
different places I mean I don't even
understand half the crap that you guys
are even saying it's just because we run
into differences here in California
that's probably why it doesn't make any
sense
I don't watch Fox TV so I mean I just
don't quite understand the mindset that
you did you read the proposal yeah but I
mean did you read the proposed that Ken
what I think we're saying on this
program maybe all we are really going
across currents here what you've written
what you think and some of the policy
prescriptions you proposed
I agree with I'd like that okay so and
that's a reason that's a reasonable
conversation what this document is is it
is it's written by the high school
socialist Club okay okay so let me just
say one thing again so and I've been
covering this beat for twenty year and
that's what we have you on when Obama
came to office and pumped and stressed a
trillion dollars in a stimulus plan to
create the new energy economy he also
was called socialist today the new
energy economy by all standards even by
the standards of this show has become
mainstream that is climate change is
accepted as real that we live solar
panels can without we have run out of
time but I want to have you back on the
program to continue this discussion okay
as it moves forward that's all the time
we have many thanks to my guests in
Washington and in San Diego and thanks
to our viewers for watching us here at
arts you see you next time and remember
crushed-up rules